[Music]
hey friends i'm scott i'm going to show
you how to customize your terminal this
is super important if you've got windows
10 or 11 you want to make sure that you
install the windows terminal you can
install this from github releases or you
can install it from the windows store
by default i've got my terminal set up
to use powershell as my shell there's a
difference between the terminal and the
shell it's important to know that the
terminal is this thing up here that
paints that square and the shell is the
thing that gives you your prompt down
here at the bottom so you can use dos or
powershell or bash or whatever makes you
happy but the windows terminal will
detect all of those things on your
machine as you can see right here i've
actually got
seven different potential shells set up
from the classic windows powershell to
the new cross platform powershell 7.
i've also got ubuntu
and then i can see that the windows
terminal has auto detected the command
prompt that is included with visual
studio 2022
and i've even got the azure cloud cell
so if i need a bash or powershell shell
in the cloud i can get it directly from
here as well all of this is completely
configurable that's important to note
now i think that you should spend some
time configuring your terminal and
making it your own so i'm going to click
here under settings
i'm going to go over here to the
defaults i want to point out under
appearance you can set your fonts you
can set your color scheme exactly the
way that you want you can set it as a
default and it'll it'll cascade down to
the other one so you see that i've
picked a variant
of a cascadia cove nerd font go to
nerdfonts.com and get those and then
i've picked my default color scheme and
then those will cascade down to settings
like this so here's my powershell one
you'll notice that i've got my command
line for loading up that particular
shell and then i've got additional
settings that i can dig into and in fact
i like
having a little watermark so i put an
image
actually on my terminal you can have a
terminal background that looks like
whatever makes you happy i'll show you
what that would look like with a
different
shell so i'm going to pick ubuntu and
i'm going to open that up in a different
tab
and you'll notice that down here in the
corner i've got the ubuntu logo in the
lower right corner that tells me that
i'm running ubuntu and then here you can
see i've got powershell with the
powershell logo for friends at
powershell magazine now you can see i've
got two tabs i can switch back and forth
but not only can i have multiple tabs i
can also do split screen
and i can do that a couple of different
ways i can click on one of the shells
from my profile list here and i can hold
down alt i'm going to press alt with my
left thumb and i'm going to hit alt
click on ubuntu you'll see right off the
bat it's going to split open so now i've
got powershell and windows on the left
ubuntu on the right and then i'm going
to hit control w
control w
typically closes a window or a tab in a
browser and i really like that hotkey so
i have control t for tab and ctrl w to
close it that's configurable you don't
get that by default you want to hit
settings and you're going to go over to
actions
and you can notice here i've actually
put in a hotkey to close that pane so
just a little bit of effort up front has
made a really nice experience for me
here in the windows terminal set it up
the way that i wanted it you can
actually see all of the different
hotkeys each of those is stored inside
of this json file so i can come down
here and click open json file i've
configured visual studio code to be my
default json editor so i can do it in
the gui or i can do it in visual studio
code
and let's go ahead and look for my
control w there it is right there close
pane control w
that is my settings and then i put that
up in a github gist i use a github gist
as a place to store those settings
that's really nice and flexible so that
way i can have my settings.json which is
the settings file for my windows
terminal stored in one place then i
bring it down on each of my computers
and have an experience that's super
reliable a little bit of effort up front
will get you set up nicely
take a look at the rest of the videos
that we're going to do i'm going to show
one soon on setting up oh my posh which
set up this lovely prompt right here
see you soon